12 Lego sets 24 hours one man can he
build them all in just one day probably
not but I'm still going to try this
collection is called the Lego Star Wars
helmets collection and it's made up of
11 helmets of popular Star Wars
characters as well as one additional set
that I'll show you near the end Rex took
me about 2 hours and 15 minutes
definitely not fast enough to get them
all done in time which means I'll need
to call in some
reinforcements with this handpicked team
of Lego building experts ready to go it
was now time to start the building
frenzy it may sound silly but I'm
actually proud of myself for sticking
with it and seeing all these builds
through to the end building these
helmets is a great way to connect with
your inner child it's like you're
transported back in time when you were
just a kid playing with Legos all day
long okay we didn't get all the sets
done before they had to leave but when I
woke up the next morning all I had to do
is finish the bonus set the Imperial
probe
Droid and with that they were all
finally done